hey this is presh talwalkar
solve for all real numbers x and y
such that 16 to the power of x squared
plus y
plus 16 to the power of x plus y squared
is equal to 1.
the youtube channel they don't do math
shared this problem and claimed only one
percent of students could solve it
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching
to learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
this is an extremely challenging problem
and i admit i was not able to solve it
so how can we work it out
the first thing to notice is for real
numbers x and y
16 to the power of some real number
will always be a positive number
so these two terms we're adding will be
greater than zero
therefore we can apply the arithmetic
mean geometric mean inequality
also known as the am gm inequality
for non-negative numbers a and b
we always have the arithmetic mean
a plus b all over 2
is greater than or equal to the
geometric mean which is the square root
of the product of a and b
furthermore
equality holds if and only if a is equal
to b
it is oftentimes useful to rewrite this
inequality by multiplying both sides by
2 so we have the sum of a and b is
greater than or equal to 2 times the
square root of the product of a and b
so let's apply the amgm inequality to
this problem
we are summing two terms which we know
are greater than zero
by the amgm inequality
this will be greater than or equal to
two times the square root of their
product
we're now going to rewrite this
expression in many ways
but we will keep this greater than or
equal to sign so that we remember that 1
is greater than or equal to the result
so first we'll rewrite the square root
as raising to the power of 0.5
then 16 is equal to 4 squared
we have 4 squared being raised to some
power
so we can simplify this by taking the
product
now
this two
and this point five will cancel out in
each of these terms
from here we will further simplify the
exponents
we will group the x terms in one
exponent and the y terms in the other
so we have 4 to the power of x squared
plus x multiplied by 4 to the power of y
plus y squared
then 2 is equal to 4 to the power of 0.5
and 0.5 is equal to 0.25 plus 0.25 so we
will put 4 to the power of 0.25 in each
of these exponents in the product
so this is equal to 4 to the power of x
squared plus x plus 0.25 multiplied by 4
to the power of y plus y squared plus
0.25
we will factor each of these exponents
the first factors to be x plus 0.5 the
quantity squared and the second is y
plus 0.5 the quantity squared
now what's interesting about these
exponents
well each is a square term
so each exponent will be greater than or
equal to zero
four raised to a power that's greater
than or equal to zero will be greater
than or equal to one
so this product will be greater than or
equal to one
but now we've shown something
interesting
we've shown that one is equal to
something and it's greater than or equal
to all these expressions and finally 1
is greater than or equal to 1.
so we've now squeezed all of these
expressions between 1.
now of course 1 is equal to 1. that
means each of these inequalities must
actually be an equality
so all of these are equal to one
in particular let's look at the last two
expressions
we must have 1 is equal to the product
4 raised to the power of x plus 0.5
squared
and 4 raised to the power of y plus 0.5
squared
but remember each of these exponents is
greater than or equal to zero because we
have a square term
four raised to zero is equal to one so
it must be the case that each of these
is equal to four to the power of zero
so that means zero is equal to each
exponent zero is equal to the square of
x plus 0.5 and zero is equal to the
square of y plus 0.5
we can solve these equations
to get that x is equal to y is equal to
negative 0.5 and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time